towns and villages and not West Syria
under attack by government jets a grim
reality throughout the nine years civil
war but for the first time the
government assault in Eid Lib has put
Turkey and the Syrian regime in a direct
military confrontation
ass after turkey sent Murray
reinforcements into Syria which says was
to prevent more bloodshed in the
province its soldiers and civilians came
under attack prompting a retaliation
from Ankara what we see is an aerial
assault by regime forces in Italy which
results in 8 people dying 5 soldiers and
three civilians and we concluded that it
was unacceptable and retaliation was
carried out the UN says it's alarmed
this escalation underscores yet again
the threat to regional and international
peace and security
pause caused by the ongoing conflict in
Syria we also remain deeply concerned by
the continuing reports of civilian
casualties large-scale displacement of
civilians turkey says nearly a million
people are moving towards its border to
escape the relentless bombing campaign
by the Syrian government it's fast
capturing towns and villages in Eid Lib
and Aleppo provinces leaving destroyed
neighborhoods and devastated families
homeless once again in Syria's harsh
winter this family of nine never stood a
chance
Oh a union as he these people were
coming they were displaced
we heard the airstrike we came running
and found the bus burning and inside
there were bodies small children over
the past few weeks Syrian government
forces have been trying to secure two
major highways that link cities under
government control and isolate the
rebels the m4 highway runs from west to
east and the m5 highway from north to
south
connecting Aleppo to the capital
Damascus and Latakia after the latest
Russian bad government advance some
Turkish observation posts built to
monitor a ceasefire net-lib are now
surrounded the Russians are saying
nothing really happened no Turkey
bombardment kind of in denial meaning
that these weaves wiggling space to try
and find some kind of magic formula to
prevent the head
collision Russian military per se have
their own political interests inside
Syria where they would want to help the
Syrian regime the Quinns out strategies
on the battlefield with dangerous
consequences and a tragic human cost
Priyanka Gupta al-jazeera